♪ ♪
>> A SCHOOL DISTRICT IN MISSOURI
GOING SUPER OLD-FASHIONED,
BRINGING BACK.
CHILDREN WHO ACTED UP, THEY WILL
NOW BE SPOTTED WITH A PADDLE AS
A "LAST RESORT."
PARENTS HAVE TO BE OKAY WITH IT
AND GIVE THE SCHOOL EXPLICIT
WRITTEN PERMISSION.
SOME MOMS AND DADS HAVE BEEN
THANKING THE SCHOOL FOR DOUBLING
DOWN ON DISCIPLINE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> YOU GOT PADDLED.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THIS FORM OF
PUNISHMENT?
>> IT WORKS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> IT NEVER HAPPENED AGAIN.
MY PARENTS WERE SO EMBARRASSED.
GOT THEIR HANDS UP WHEN I GOT
HOME AS WELL.
[LAUGHTER]
I DON'T HAVE AN ISSUE WITH THIS.
>> APPARENTLY IT'S LEGAL.
>> THEY SAID THAT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT THE INDIVIDUAL STATES --
WHETHER THEY WILL ALLOW IT.
THE CONCEPT IS THAT IF A TEACHER
IS A LOCAL -- AND IN THE PLACE
OF THE PARENT, AND THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT ARE SMART, THEY ARE
SAYING TO THE PARENTS "IF YOU
WANT US TO HAVE PERMISSION TO
WHACK YOUR KID --" >> TAKE THEM
OUT TO.
[LAUGHTER]
AND THEY SAY, APPARENTLY -- BUT
THEY DO NOT SAY THAT H.
I ASSUME IT'S GRAMMAR SCHOOL >>
WE NEVER DID THIS IN THE
NORTHEAST, DID WE?
>> THEY SAID THEY ARE MOSTLY IN
THE SOUTH.
BUT, EVERYONE GOT HIT IN SCHOOL.
IT WAS BY NUNS.
THEY WERE A LOT ANGRIER BACK
THEM.
>> THAT IS WHY MY AUNTS LOOK
LIKE THIS.
>> WHATEVER IT WAS, YOU WERE
GETTING HIT.
THE TV WAS BLACK-AND-WHITE.
I WILL SAY THIS: HAVING THAT
PADDLE, THE THREAT -- "YOUR
PARENTS ARE AROUND THE CORNER,
DO YOU WANT THE PADDLE?"
[LAUGHTER]
JUST THE THREAT.
MY MOM WOULD NOT SPOON FOR
EATING -- FOR.
THIS WOULD BE IF I DID SOMETHING
BAD.
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU HAVE
EATING DISORDERS.
[LAUGHTER]
ON HIS CROSS-COUNTRY SHOW
SATURDAY NIGHT.
THERE IS A TEACHER SHORTAGE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT SOME OF
THE TEACHERS ARE SAYING IS THAT
MANY ARE LEAVING BECAUSE
STUDENTS IN THE CLASSROOM --
BEHAVIORAL ISSUES THAT ARE OUT
OF CONTROL.
YOU DISRESPECT YOUR TEACHERS,
IT'S A HUGE PROBLEM.
NOT EXAGGERATED, IT HAS COME
BACK.
I CAN UNDERSTAND PARENTS --" BUT
ALSO, DON'T WANT TEACHERS TO
DEAL WITH THE SENSITIVE TOPICS
LIKE GENDER ISSUES, FOR EXAMPLE.
LOOKING TO DO THAT AT HOME.
I WOULD WANT TO TAKE CARE OF THE
PADDLING MYSELF >> ON THE BUTT,
RIGHT?
>> YES, NOT ON THE HANDS.
>> YOU CAN'T CAUSE PHYSICAL
HARM.
PHYSICAL HARM, PHYSICAL INJURIES
WHERE YOU LEAVE A MARK.
>> BUT HOW DO YOU KNOW?
>> THE PARENTS WILL TELL YOU.
>> THE KIDS ARE GOING TO SUE THE
SCHOOL, AND IT WILL NEVER BE THE
SAME.
>> THE PARENTS AGREED TO THE.
>> WE ARE GOING TO S